welcome back to the iced coffee hour and
today we're having on bobby misner now
bobby was infamous from a video he
posted about three years ago titled life
of a billionaire's son where he
showcased the lifestyle of growing up
with a billion dollars a viral video
with tons of women private jets and all
these other luxuries that is completely
detached from your and my reality
exactly so that's why we gotta have him
on the iced coffee hour and confront him
about what it's like to grow up as a
billionaire's son enjoy and also big
thanks to ftx us for sponsoring this
episode if you guys want to trade crypto
and nfts with no fees whatsoever which
is pretty unheard of check out ftx with
a link down below in the description and
also ethos life insurance if you guys
are looking to sign up for life
insurance ethos is the best they're
super fast and easy check them out in
the link down below in the description
let's begin what's up guys i'm bobby
mesner welcome to the iced coffee hour
podcast so far they have generated over
2
million dollars in adsense revenue
where'd you get that number from
did you
do it one more time yeah no no no that
was good that was fine let's know yeah
yeah
we've made about 200 000 of that yeah
203 000 23 000 yeah close i just figured
you guys had a super high cpm because of
like you're talking about finance and
stuff oh my gosh
not that not that high
yeah it's pretty good but anyway man
thank you so much for coming all the way
out to las vegas happy birthday by the
way it was just the other day yeah it
was just yesterday thank you very much i
am now 27. let's have a whole year to
survive without joining the 27 club so
i'm going to be taking it very easily
all right yeah you might want to scale
back on some of the parties and uh you
know the fast lifestyle
maybe read a book watch some youtube
slow cards you know yeah exactly be in
the backseat but anyway man thank you so
much for coming out and uh no joke i
have seen i've watched almost all of
your videos since the very first one you
posted the life of a billionaire's son
yeah and i remember when you posted that
video and i got like three million views
and what probably seems like two days it
got it went yeah it got to two million
in a week but it was like crazy because
i
i was just like there like this kid like
thinking i'm gonna go viral i'm gonna go
viral like thinking like all this like
everyone's like what are you doing
you're getting like 100 views
um and i was like you guys don't get it
like you guys don't get it like my
life's cool you're gonna see and then
like six months after trying to make
videos i made that i had like you know a
thousand subscribers 500 of them fake
and
all of a sudden i just start the video
just starts going crazy so it gets like
50k in a couple days and then it gets a
couple hundred thousand then it goes
friday and we go out we're celebrating
and i wake up in the morning at a
million overnight so it was like two mil
and that's without anyone making a
reaction video and then all of a sudden
everyone just starts like making videos
on it i'm like on the home page i'm
[ __ ] it was just crazy how did you
grow up
who is your father what did he do
and how was that changed throughout the
last few years um so i grew up with a
with my single mom most of my parents
were divorced when i was like you know
like three or four years old they were
already divorced so i didn't really know
any anything else
live with my mom and my older sister
my dad would sometimes come to visit
give me birthday presents basically come
like once a year because he was very
busy building his company
and then um so i was always like going
to private schools and stuff but i never
was like one of the spoiled kids who had
a bunch of stuff i was always very like
wearing second-hand clothes and shitty
shoes and never had any cool toys or
anything right um except for my dad
would give me a birthday present
um what would a birthday present look
like was he was he wealthy back then
yeah he was still he was still you know
he was making money but he wasn't like
extraordinarily like wealthy
compared to now or like compared to now
oh okay but he's still like he was still
worth gonna be like 20 million
dollars all right but i had no idea
right yeah sure what would the presence
be that's a good question yeah the
presence would be like a game console or
i had like a quad bike mini quad it
would always be something cool okay you
know
which would make up for the fact that he
wasn't there because
i was just like a materialistic kid yeah
yeah we got a quad bike
so
i mean it was interesting growing up
though with all these rich kids knowing
that my dad was had money but i just
wasn't living with him or didn't have
any of that lifestyle go or ever go on a
holiday or anything okay um i was always
just at home
so when i was like 15 and i was in i was
in
german international school
international school in germany
um
and then
i was getting kicked out i wasn't
allowed to continue i've been kicked out
of a bunch of schools already and then
my dad like sells his company for 300
million and he's like he's he stands he
just shows me like a bank statement i
was like oh i was at the house he just
put on the bet and he showed me a bank
statement it was like cash and he's like
in his bank so 300 million dollars cash
in his bank account and he had before he
saw the company he'd made residency in
dubai so what did you what did your dad
do exactly i knew he's in the music
industry correct yeah yeah yeah so he
started off
in the music industry he was like a
sound engineer and a guitar player
um and then he started to realize that
nobody was teaching how to be
a music producer or sound engineer
anything like that there was no way to
learn you just had to like get an
internship so he started teaching he was
working as a sound engineer and then
he'd start teaching after he'd finish
work and just have people come in
and then that's sort of how he started
making money then he bought this studio
called studio 301 and then he started
making loads of schools and i don't know
i mean i was just a kid so they started
expanding and expanding globally but it
was a school that he he made was like a
creative media college it was like the
biggest one in the world and then
eventually just he sold all of it but he
kept a real estate so like they still
like rent it from him so 300 million
dollars what year was this like how old
were you when that happened um i was 15
yeah and so when he shows you a bank
statement how does that register for you
at 15 is it just well my dad's a big
flex he's a flexible yeah okay no he
likes he likes to flex you know he made
all his money on his own so it's like
it's it's cool it's very cool for him so
you know i don't know it was just it was
like wow it was like right as a hella
rich
that's that's what was going through
your mind my dad's rich now i was like
yeah did you feel entitled to that did
you feel like some of that's mine too um
definitely okay i think it was like a
big learning curve going because like i
get thrown into boarding school there's
probably
50 other kids there with 100 million
plus families all of a sudden it becomes
like this big dick contest like you
people all everyone googles who
everyone's family is at boarding school
so everyone knows who everyone is and if
your parents are like super loaded
you're part of a certain group what
group were you a part of like who were
who are the parents of those kids like
the
rich kids but like the bad ones like the
ones who would just party and not really
do and is that how you got kicked out of
the school that's how i ended up getting
kicked out yeah okay who were their
parents are they yeah yeah so like one
of my best friend charlie break he went
to love island actually his parents
owned brakes which is a huge catering
company in the uk okay by the boy henry
lloyd they're in like lloyd murders big
biggest bmw dealership in the north and
yeah like all everyone would just be
like super loaded um and then you're
just like basically all your your
objective is is to spend your entire
allowance really um
by going to london for an exiat weekend
you get like one per month or something
you can go to london for a saturday
saturday night because you've got
saturday school and that was really the
objective was going out and getting
bottles and nobody had ids you had to
pay an extra 100 to this promoter
whoever name but you have to pay mr
hundred dollars and you get in it was
fun what were most allowances like at
that age
you know most kids it depends like like
i said like that circle of like these
really really rich kids
they would be getting like a lot more
money than me
so it was a lot of like me like they
knew who my dad was but my dad was
self-made so he didn't like throw me
cash and stuff like this and just let me
have whatever i want so i was always
like part of it but then also having to
like sort of blag like like what but how
big of an allowance would they get they
would get like anywhere between five and
ten thousand a month while they were at
school oh my gosh yeah jeez there was
this kid
yeah he his parents like owned like
mcdonald's and caterpillar in egypt he
came into my house in my boarding house
and uh he had like no cloth like really
like just whatever clothes
um i get assigned as like his bigger
brother or like to look after him and
show him the school for like the first
couple days and um he's like what are
you wearing i was like wearing dolce
gabon like that was the thing to have
and he's like he's like okay cool and
then like he comes back next week the
entire collection he just has the entire
collection industry i'm like who is this
kid
he's like he goes by but he's just like
the richest he's probably the richest
person i know in the world now how much
would that cost to buy the entire club
what does that consist of
like that of that season 50k
yeah wow because he just had cash he
just he said he would run he didn't have
any cards either because he came from
like egypt at the time it was like a lot
of
going on so he always had cash sometimes
he'd run out and he'd ask me if i could
like lend him 20 to go to the tuck shop
in in in our house and you get candy and
[ __ ] because he wouldn't he couldn't
withdraw cash so he has to go back home
get his money and then you know what i'm
saying yeah was that a compliment that
you said dolce gabbana and he's just
like all right i'm gonna yeah do that
like you influenced him a little bit
yeah big brother right there yeah had
you said any other brand you'd be buying
that
you should
you should have joked with them and be
like that's h m
and he would have spent like a thousand
dollars since buying the entire
i have a collection about uh
you know money and and happiness for you
bobby
one do you think that money can buy you
happiness and then you know you
mentioned your dad was working and you
only got like a gift or two or whatever
would you trade
you know and not like a complete swap
but like would you trade maybe a little
bit less money
for a little bit more of your dad's
presence growing up
um
hmm
i
i would have so maybe start with the
first one if it helps you think about it
a little bit so do you think money can
buy you happiness yeah so i mean i think
money can
definitely buy you the ability to have
enough time to be happy to figure out
how to be happy right and like what
makes you happy and all that because if
you just don't have any money i feel
like the only thing you can thinking
about is like how to get money and how
to
eat and like pay your rent and
everything so if i think if you're just
worrying about those things all the time
it's kind of hard to be happy because
you're just worried you know what i'm
saying so i think money definitely buys
you freedom and time and then after that
it's like about you know there's so many
ways to figure out what makes you happy
you know whether that's partying and
then you figure out that's not it and
then it's a girl but i think
you know it's it's always up and down
but
money definitely gives you the freedom
and the time to to find happiness now is
the perfect time to buy crypto but
finding a reputable trustworthy exchange
is not always easy that's why we
recommend that if you're going to be
buying and selling crypto do so with the
exchange that we use the most ftx we
both use the ftx app we just love how
simple and easy it is to use and best of
all when buying and selling crypto and
nfts so many other exchanges have fees
but ftx has no fees and best of all you
could get all the way up to 100 with a
free crypto when you trade with ftx us
and you'll get free crypto on every
trade over ten dollars they're one of
the largest exchanges in the world as
trusted by millions of users and guys
graham doesn't know this yet but they're
soon gonna be launching ftx stocks and
their plan is to be an all-in-one
finance app so ftx is all you'll ever
need i personally love just how easy it
is to use and how simple it is to trade
they also allow you to do recurring buys
into the markets that you could dollar
cost average in on a regular basis
without even thinking about it to start
trading crypto and nfts today with no
fees once again guys that is no fees by
downloading the ftx app with the link
down below in the description again the
link is down below in the description to
get started today with no fees
thank you so much ftx and back to the
podcast and then what about the second
question um
i think
even if it's like you know let's say he
made
50 mil less yeah but you know you got to
see him let's say once a month or
something you know i or you know yeah it
could be even just a little bit or would
you leave it exactly you know how you
how it was
i think i'd leave it how it was i mean i
think it's he made a big sacrifice to
make all that money you know what i mean
i think he wanted he wanted more than
anything to have a family because he
grew up an early child
so
and he wanted to look after his family
and he knew that
money was obviously super important um
and he wanted you know i think he wanted
to set it up so that we're good for
generations to come which i i think i
wouldn't have i wouldn't have traded
more seeing my dad more for
you know a couple hundred million less
why would i do that you know what i'm
saying because me my dad would think the
same anyway at the end of the day you
know what i mean i'm going to send my
kid to boarding school when he's [ __ ]
12 years old
now how much of an allowance did you get
when they're getting 10 5 10 000 a month
yeah i was getting like 1200 a month
okay pounds how would you spend that
um
i'd spend it
pretty stupidly yeah yeah like either
like you know try buy like one thing
that was designer and then go out
clubbing
because you wouldn't spend any money
when you're in school
you know
do you think that the boarding school
kind of amplified all of that like if
you went to a non-boarding school do you
think there would be that like
competition yeah where it's like who's
spending the most yeah i think boarding
school definitely amplifies the whole
rich kids scene thing like a lot and
everyone's on their own so everyone's
sort of like
you you're just listening to what
everyone else is saying and that's how
you'll figure out like what's important
and what's not right
but i think it also gives you a good
deal of independence by going there you
know what i'm saying because you're
doing your own laundry you're looking
after yourself you have to do your own
homework you're gonna do everything
yourself your parents aren't there to
look after you and pick all the pieces
you know i'm saying and the house
parents are very strict and make you
like be disciplined
is that why because i never understood
boarding school because i guess like in
in la
it's either you go to a public or
private school and that and that's
really it i don't know anybody that went
to a boarding school is that just not
common as much in the u.s or like what's
the advantage why
or is it because the parents just like
want more time off what's the i think um
it's just super prestigious and like
when you go there you make a lot of
connections for life you know what i'm
saying for me it's like i still know
and i'm still very good friends with a
lot of people from my school and a lot
of them are doing incredible things and
are in very powerful positions so i
think it's all it's very much so about
connections there's why people go to
these prestigious boarding schools is to
put their kids around other kids who are
you know from super wealthy families and
they know that that's how you get that's
how you're going to get up in life you
know what i'm saying is by having the
right connections that's what i've
always been taught
so
do you know how much boarding school
cost it's like 33 000 pounds a year like
45 grand yeah there's some that are
ridiculous like in switzerland i was
that was i was told like either you go
to switzerland england and i was like
i'm not gonna be in like freezing cold
and like speaking german like
so i went to england but there's some
sweet there's some swiss school like le
rose
which is like you know i think it's like
150 000 a year or something what's the
process like to get in because i take it
like even if you have the money they're
not gonna be like all right come on in
yeah it depends on the school like there
are like eaton and harrah which are all
boys schools and there's a couple others
which are like top top top schools where
all the kids get a's and everything but
you to get in there you have to
you have to go there when you're 13. you
can't like go there later or anything
like the school that i went to is
milfield is like the biggest sporting
school so they have a lot of kids there
in scholarship so the re the rest of it
but it's such a big school that they
fill the rest of the spaces up no matter
what so they just let
that's where all the screw-ups kind of
go would you say it provided you with a
better education i think it definitely
provided me
with
no because i did i wasn't i didn't i
didn't
do enough i wasn't doing the homework
and stuff like this but i think it
definitely provided me with independence
at an earlier age than than than if i
didn't go and having an inside look on
so many
children of extremely wealthy people
what is some stereotype or something
that you've noticed that just completely
differs these types of people from the
average person i'd say a lot of them
i don't know i don't really know did you
notice the difference between those
types of people and yeah i mean it's
definitely like the their
manners
um
often very polite the people like my
friends that went to boarding school you
know there's obviously like an essence
of them be more pretentious than a lot
of people there's a lot of things that i
i don't really i don't really care about
doing luck stuff i don't care where i
sleep or anything like that i'm very
very easy going australian at the end of
the day see what i'm saying so i don't
really care what what i'm doing or if
it's lux or not but some of them are
like
almost like
afraid of like doing something that
isn't nice or staying somewhere that
isn't nice do you know what i mean which
i always find like kind of lame like i i
don't really care you know what i mean
you can crash on a friend's house you
don't get you're in a you know on a
couch somewhere
best western yeah
yeah six okay yeah
why did you get kicked out what happened
there
um
well i'd been kicked out of a lot of
schools already um
and then what happened at middlefield
was
i
already had like a bad track record for
the most of the year most of the i was
there for two years last two years of
school the senior senior senior school i
had a really bad track track record i'd
been messing around you know skipping
school doing this that the other so i
was on a red report card which basically
means like you have to
every single class you have to get the
teacher to sign it to say that you were
very well behaved you did your work um
you did your prep when you were at house
you it's just like you're on like very
thin ice and then at that point it was
my birthday which is around exams time
in may 6th yesterday it was like the
same time exams were happening
and
i was like i told my parents that it was
a public holiday on monday
and i had my mom's email so i started
emailing the the headmistress and i'm
saying like yeah i got a visa
appointment in germany that i have to
like go to
and all this and then me and my boy
henry
and charlie were gonna go my boy charlie
like freaked out last minute didn't come
so it's just me and henry went down to
my my dad's yacht in monaco
um and we're just on that
we went out in can we went to monaco we
saw this guy like lose a million in in
in like maybe 10 minutes right next to
us it was insane just gambling just yeah
okay just lost it i was like okay he
just like didn't care
so i mean it was pretty fun you know
with jet skiing and everything this is
when snapchat was big instagram didn't
have stories yet so everyone at school
starts seeing that we're just in
saturday and starts talking and
everyone's talking about it we get back
and like we're just in huge trouble and
they're like this is the last straw i go
into the office with the headmistress
and the headmaster and they're like
basically saying like yeah like we're
gonna like they ask you to leave right
they never expel kids from from these
kind of schools unless it's drugs so
they're like trying to ask me to leave
and i was like no like i think i'll stay
that sounds like me no no i'm good
jack he's like make the decision i was
like yeah i think i'll stay i can be i
can be do all my work it's fine i'll
stay i'll stay and then she's like
wrong answer and i was like
oh it's not like a choice thing is it
we're asking you to leave now what would
happen if you just didn't and be like no
i'm not
i couldn't well she said like if i did
that then i make one mistake and she
said then you're expelled and then
that's when you're on your thing did
these teachers or headmasters say uh
ever get any like nice gifts from like
fam you know the families of the kids
that were there at all i don't know
about gifts but i'm i know that
you know some some families would donate
like a building or something oh and then
that kid would just be allowed to do
whatever they wanted okay that's the end
of the game yeah were there any
repercussions of you going out and maybe
getting expelled from these schools or
suspended or whatever and getting in
trouble did your parents ever get upset
at you um my mom was like
she thinks that i was just so amazing so
it was always like i would get away with
it and because i was just living with my
mom um and she would never tell my dad
she never would tell my dad that i was
getting in trouble or anything until
like the very end when i got like
expelled and then like my dad had this
big talk with me and it was just like a
very like real like talk about like what
are you doing like where are you going
well that was that time that you went to
monaco that you got like expelled yeah
okay what was that talk like what it was
it was pretty hectic yeah because i've
never really like have talked so when he
talks to me it means a lot because he
doesn't ever like sort of try to push me
in any direction or anything he's very
careful about that because he knows that
you know maybe i'm just going to do the
other the opposite but i think this is a
very very powerful talk
um and definitely like made me realize
what do i what i actually wanted to do
and what
what i needed to do which wasn't to go
to university basically i was like i'm
not gonna that's just gonna be a waste
of time for me at the end of the day so
i was like you know i need to figure it
out started working in a bar in
australia
um and then i came back started working
with my dad and that's when i later on
started i was like i want to make
youtube videos how was that working at a
bar wouldn't you look at that and be
like i was making this allowance and i'm
like i'm making less at the bar that my
buddy's getting for an allowance
no so i was in australia yeah so you
earn a lot of money how much were you
making it i was making like a thousand
dollars a week yeah but still less than
you know the other guy's allowance yeah
like did that bother you at all i think
when i was younger it did but
um
once i got to like 21
i sort of um
actually when i got to 20 i got just
like 21 my dad gave me a lot of money to
like buy an apartment i kept it for a
year or something and i sold it and then
i just had like you know
probably like 700 000
in my bank account and i was like i'm
gonna go to la
and it was gone
all seven hundred dollars yeah he's just
gone
it's gone it's all it's all gone it's
gone it's gone it's all gone
it took me like a year yeah wow seven
hundred thousand dollars in a year yeah
that's still i mean two thousand dollars
a day yeah i was just where is it whoa i
you know it's
when you're
bottle service
yeah i'm guessing rent bottle service i
wasn't getting rent because i wasn't
paying rent i was saying in airbnbs
hotels
i was flying around like business class
i mean you could spend a thousand
dollars instead of canceling my flight i
just miss it and book another one
and i take goals on trips to like new
york or what i i was just like
i just
thought that it was i just had like so
much money and you realize that it isn't
a lot of money when did you realize that
it wasn't a lot of money um
when it kind of like ended after a year
and i was just like wow like
when it was getting down to what like
when it was like when i was like down
like 40 000. that's when it really
slowed down you were just like oh i
probably made that other the last 40 000
stretch like another six months yeah
why wouldn't you just call your dad be
like hey you know my bad
yeah
he went too fast he was upset he was
like he's like you're a [ __ ] idiot
you know but wouldn't you see that like
the writings on the wall like the first
month that you're spending all this
money
did you check this
hey do your things be responsible yeah
he didn't really like yeah i mean it was
also kind of like a big learning curve
as well i think he wanted me to realize
you know
that
you know that it's not that much money
at the end of the day if you want to
start living like that um
which was a big it was a big like
realization you know i'm saying and i
think now i definitely have a lot more
respect for money
um i'm definitely like a lot more
focused on earning it very like i don't
spend
at like i always try to like not spend
and always try to buy the cheapest thing
and all this stuff so like i think it
definitely helped me because i sort of
realized like
i want to be rich again so
first we gotta thank our sponsor ethos
as some of you may know i bought a house
recently and although i haven't started
a family yet i wouldn't want to leave
them with a mortgage that they couldn't
afford if something bad would ever
happen you know i think the idea of
needing life insurance is a difficult
one to come to terms with but
considering life insurance rates could
go up by 8 to 10 a year now is a better
time than ever thankfully though ethos
is a life insurance provider that gives
you life insurance that's fast easily
accessible and best of all affordable
traditional life insurance has been
confusing expensive and time consuming
but with ethos you can get a quote in
seconds apply in minutes and get covered
the same day in most cases only 10
minutes could protect your family for as
little as 10 dollars per month ethos
offers a variety of policies to make
sure there's a policy right for you some
policies offer level premiums which
means what you pay now is what you'll be
paying in 30 years if you're interested
in learning more about ethos or getting
your free life insurance quote the link
is down below in the description to
apply today guys it's literally free
there's no reason not to do it go click
that link down below in the description
to apply for a free quote today thank
you so much ethos for sponsoring this
episode and back to the podcast so what
happened when you got down to that last
40
was was your dad giving you any more
money or was he just like you gotta find
a way to make it work i was still had
like
yeah no he wasn't really
um
[Music]
giving me any money but then that's when
i popped off because i was coming down
to the end of the money and i was like i
need to do something and i made that
life a billionaire son video and it
worked and then all of a sudden like you
know i got a job working like filming a
festival for disney and then i was
working for french montana wow
wait did you produce that video yourself
which one life of a building is that
bright yeah yeah yeah yeah what was it
it was all it was the whole story and
all the everything was like me
but then brandon at the time just like
helped me sound like he would
at the end he would come in and he was
like he would like look at what i was
saying and he would either make a little
bit shorter
um
and he came up with the part where i
said uh the rich kid stereotype and how
i wanted to break that
because it was something else it was
something different before that so like
he came up with that part how much did
that video make you like adsense nothing
because it was all i use like super
copyrighted music oh that's right okay
because here's the thing like i didn't
go like for me it's like i want to see
that video in like 50 years from now and
be like wow that's still sick i don't
want to look back and be like wow that
stock music is really cool i'm glad i
used the stock music you know what i
mean yeah i'm going to be a billionaire
like why am i worried about making 20
000 off something that i want just to be
a cool video forever you know why do you
say you're going to be billing there how
well i'm going to inherit it at some
point you know well
let's get there but but you said you got
deals with like disney instead how did
that happen
montana well the video just started
going off yeah this guy i know he owns a
big like uh
digital marketing company
and he was like yeah these guys these
french companies have been filming they
were organizing a lecture land at disney
it's in power disneyland paris and uh
they were like yeah this french company
has been filming at these old french
guys and like they kind of suck so we're
gonna have you come in
but we had to we did it for half the
price that these guys are doing it but
they did at the same time we're both
filming those that we were filming
against each other and it was just me
and my boy
and like i'm just running around with
the with the a7 just getting like some
cool like handheld shots and in the
crowd and all this stuff and then he's
got the red camera and just smoked these
guys just like blew them out of the
[ __ ] one like they're like one guy
had like a helmet cam he was like
wearing a guy wow
what the [ __ ] are these guys doing
how much you get paid for that we could
pay like 12k okay
in pounds though
16 17 000 u.s yeah so how much are you
making right now
right now i make money from i probably
make like 5k a month
from everything from like yeah
sometimes a little bit more depends but
i have like because i have a members
club and we do like trips yeah basically
um and then i can make a movie out of it
so we did a trip to like mykonos cape
town we did coachella
um
which is cool yeah but that's kind of
like what i wanna i love the most doing
because i love just filming parties and
and holidays and like stuff like that
yeah but so if you're making like five
thousand dollars a month i look at your
videos and i think this lifestyle costs
30 grand a month maybe 40 000 a month
where does that difference come from
like how do you get that lifestyle um
just because i know a lot of people
i feel i feel like a lot of the things
that i do is because i know people
um and i managed to like make it look
bigger than it is i'm very good at
making things look cooler than they are
but what about your like the rent the
rent's got to be like 16 grand a month
yeah 18 something like that uh yeah so i
mean i'm paying like
three really yeah so you rent out that
house with other people yeah they they
have the lease i'm just like renting uh
jesus because they're my friends
that's a good that's a good price for
that place it's right off of like sunset
boulevard in west hollywood like that
location is prime and what about like
the cars you're driving like a
ferrari was it a 308 or 328 ferrari yeah
yeah i'll just that i'll like rent them
or ask like a friend who has a car or
something okay what about the food what
about okay so i'm guessing
we're gonna get this the nightclubs i'm
guessing you just get it
so yeah so that there's no customer like
if you're like cool i guess it's the
only place that this works if you're
like cool you can just go out and drink
for free and party and everything and
they kind of want you there it's weird
yes like every other every other place
in europe they'll be like what are you
doing like you have to buy a table or
something
going out it's free what food
how do you um i shop at costco
no i'm talking about like the
restaurants i guess
i see i see you at these restaurants
where they're bringing out just like you
know the crab that like has this oh like
yeah i'm going
to cause i'm like be with someone just
doing it you know and they'll pay for or
it's just like yeah or promoter dinner
or stuff it could be more frugal than i
am man
that's impressive
i you're living you're living a forty
thousand dollar month livestream okay
private jets do you just you just get
invited on private um
no like maybe like three times on other
people's jets i've only ever the murray
stuff being is like ours oh yeah cause
your family probably has one yeah yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
um so you fly here with a private jet no
no they don't like let me like use it
like that how did you get here um you
drive or fly oh i yeah i flew from la to
here yeah what what airlines spirit
spirit airlines did you really yeah well
get flies from burbank yeah and i didn't
want to go to lax it's annoying
you didn't use jet sweep jet sweet axe
flies from burbank too i know but italic
brown i'm not rich like that bro i'm
just like [ __ ] cooling you know what
i'm saying is it are you worried
but are you worried are you serious if
someone sees you on spirit like if i saw
you with spirit i'd be like
bobby i know but that's you know like
people don't understand like i don't
give a [ __ ] like i'm happy to just live
breadline and like smoke weed and be
chilling on a beach like that's me like
that's how i grew up you know what i'm
saying is just like chilling and like
i'm happy with that so it's like
money is like super cool to me and i
love like doing those things but without
it i'm exactly the same and i'm still
laughing so it's not like your lifestyle
necessarily requires money or at least
you're happy
my happiness doesn't work exactly
because when you know that it you have
like an 80 million dollar house a jet
and your dad's like this that the other
you it sort of removes any like i don't
ever feel like i need to prove anything
to anyone do you know what i'm saying if
you wanted to you could just go move
back in with your dad or something like
yeah i mean i could live in santa pay
but it's boring yeah driving those races
it's boring jack
want to go in today but it's like burn
like it's it's it's boring like to to be
in la and like when you're part of that
scene to then go to la is like
everyone's like oh wow like because they
most people can't do that what yeah
what's the la scene that you're talking
about because that's where i grew up you
know i like what i could describe that
yes the scene in like in europe like all
the high society like that that vibe
to
for them for me to go out to la it's
like oh wow like he's out there that's
so crazy because to them like it's such
a distant
land with movie stars and like i don't
understand you know what i mean so i
think that's that's cool so could you
break down your expenses for us from
like five grand a month
three of its rent
you're left with two how do you spend
that other two well i have an average
like probably another like 1500
allowance and then it depends like
sometimes 35 okay so sometimes i'll make
like
other money like from random things sure
you know
like connecting someone to someone or
or
like doing a random story post about
likable nft how much could you make uh
connecting someone to someone else
anywhere between like a
1500 and like
10k i think i made most 10k who do you
connect for 10k well like for like
blockchain development or something oh
okay okay a lot of that or
um
amazon e-commerce automated stores and
[ __ ] like i don't know i have some
friends like they just do [ __ ] and
that's like i'll introduce them to
someone who might want to do it you know
you just
collect a little bit of that
introduction yeah and then what about
french montana um yeah i was working for
friends i think he's a videographer i
did that for like
three months and then i was like this is
horrible i don't want to be a door
videographer like i want to make my
videos yeah i don't need to do this you
know what i mean um but it was cool to
go on we went to the middle east like it
was sick you know i'm saying i'm friends
with french now and everything so that's
cool and then afterwards then i started
working for a designer yeah i saw i saw
him in one of your videos yeah she's
like hanging out in the kitchen
yeah
what would you need to connect us with
designer get designer on the podcast he
would come with a party would he
actually would a video would have been
here right now are you serious would he
actually no way let's do that yeah
should we call him yes is he is he in
vegas serious
is he invasive not in vegas no
we get damn it we call him his birth
holy birthday no way he doesn't he
doesn't know does he know you're doing
this no i didn't know you i i didn't oh
my gosh no i saw him in your videos like
that's so cool yeah i'm a big i'm a big
fan of the panther yeah panda no no no
just he makes that sound all the time i
love it
i can't do it but yeah i love it so many
numbers oh my gosh
wait that's nuts
you know yeah just casually call people
i know blows me yeah okay so so
let's call design but like who else
you don't have to call it i'm not gonna
ask you to call anybody else but i'm
like who else do you have in that that
phone
yo
[Music]
yo what the [ __ ] going on right
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
we we saw you in uh bobby's video we
liked it
in the kitchen
so i just wanted to say we really
appreciate you your music and if you're
ever in vegas we'd love to have you on
the podcast if you if you're interested
and sushi on us
that's fine let's go crazy let's go
crazy man let's go crazy
man that's my dog
all right my boy i'll see you later hey
thanks for your time man
[Music]
that blew my mind
i did the thing that just made my day
wow
that's crazy yeah it's funny so this
reminds me eric could we say oh yeah we
could say eric had uh you know eric uh
yeah yeah he had what billy eilish
called it she didn't pick up and we my
hands were like
and then like something happened where
we knew she saw it oh yeah or like a
text message said red yeah yes if you
could call it like the iced coffee hour
or something like that it's red
but never got back to it you know like
eric's second ever video we made yeah i
was i was like in it like he like said
like he like hit me up and asked me to
buy the couch
and i didn't know anything was going on
i was like
i should have bought it now i look back
but i was like what do you mean the cat
i don't want to buy a couch and then
like and then whatever and then he like
puts it in he's like i contacted all
these people contacted bobby miserable
famous for life
would happen
and then like i was like wow this guy's
really going for it and then all of a
sudden he's getting
millions of views i was like wow yeah he
really had you but you had you bought
that couch that would have been huge
yeah i know i said the 90 000 couch
who else's number do you have there you
don't have to call anybody else and now
lindsay lohan okay um oh can we get her
on the podcast i'd pay you to get
lindsay lohan oh she won't kind of [ __ ]
she doesn't [ __ ] with me anymore bro oh
well because we like we like we like
hooked up for like a week and we were
like hanging out and [ __ ] hook up yeah
and then we were like well like i was i
don't know i was a toy boy for a week
essentially and like we you know she
took me to some parties and [ __ ] kate
moss jumped out of this [ __ ] birthday
cake and like getting packed and stuff
it was lit but then i obviously said
that i dated her in my youtube video and
she was like [ __ ] you ah so like you
know why was she upset at that which was
just like so like she just like
so over a hollywood like she lives in
dubai so she just i don't know
got it okay probably be fine if we saw
each other again but like not gonna
can't call her
got it man
yeah part of me feels like i should just
you know live off of five grand a month
just take a picture with my ford gt take
a picture with my forty thousand dollar
aquarium
you know and i don't care just like that
you know people like that stuff on
youtube yeah yeah that's insane to me
man that's insane to me i'm actually
pretty surprised i honestly thought that
the lifestyle that you were living was
like 30 40 grand a month
i mean it makes sense i think it would
be like the sensible thing to do yeah
wow you just did that
yeah i know i'm still trying to like
wrap my mind around that yeah
if we got designer in the pot like i
would i would flip
dude
if if there's any way to make that
happen anytime you just let us know hey
this time this place or obviously this
place but this time meet here and we'll
be there we'll any time
even if it's like 3 a.m i'll find a way
to make that work
he's hilarious as well sorry yeah i like
his energy he'd get me he got me hyped
up afterwards like now i'm like i'm
gonna have a great day today just the
exact same yeah
by the way did you say did you say it
was your birthday today
it's his but it was his birthday on like
wednesday oh wow oh okay nice nice
that's how we that's how we kind of
first became friends was like
well like i was filming a bit for him
and then we realized like oh bro it's
our birthday's at the same time and
that's when we threw this party at
jake's house which was just like viral
yeah which is cool wow what's your
experience been like uh going from that
to dating because i see what you have a
girlfriend now right yeah yeah so i have
a girlfriend she's french um i met her
in san tropez she's from montana
no i was kidding
get it get the joke french she's just
from montana that's such a dead
um
so
yeah i mean i have a girlfriend i've had
a girlfriend now for like almost a year
it'll be the longest girlfriend i've
ever had there we go which is which is
pretty cool
what do you like about this girl um i
like that she's very very beautiful um
she's always smiling
she's very happy like
she's just like nice the sweetest girl
is so sweet you know what i'm saying
it's important so and what's your
experience been like before her
um before
her i had like one girlfriend before her
that's it was like for like six months
or something this girl from monaco but
it ended up just being like a pretty big
heartbreak for me
what happened like we both like were
like because i was living in london at
after the summer and then she was there
and then she like cheated on me with a
guy who had like a way bigger yacht and
i like came back to monaco i was like
[ __ ] pissed and like went out with my
little sister and her friend i went to
this club in monaco and monaco everyone
sort of stands around in the club and
they're just bored and like they have
ridiculous amounts of money they were
like pyramid of kristal you're talking
like you know there's dropping like 30
40k and like nobody's excited
so like i'm in this [ __ ] started
getting drunk and i find this kid who's
who basically [ __ ] my girlfriend with a
big yacht and [ __ ] and i try to start
like a fight with him
he's look at him he's got security
he's got like all of his friends i got
my sister
and i'm just like
belligerent trying to [ __ ] fight this
guy like nobody
nobody would let me fight him because
i'm so drunk and then
and then the valet like drove me home
because i took my dad's car like a
bentley and i couldn't drive it so he
like drove me home but did this guy know
that like that was your girlfriend or is
he just having a good time it just so
happens
oh yeah you can't but i was you know
blame him
so
that's what happened but i mean
other than that you know just dated some
girls
here and there
you know
always
yeah always very aesthetic based i guess
yeah what does your girlfriend do
um she is a model and a horse rider okay
yeah
when did your your dad's net worth cross
that billion dollar mark yeah i sold
this company for 300 million now i
looked online how accurate is it that it
says his net worth is 400 million just
inaccurate here's the thing like all my
dad's money's in monaco and so nobody
knows how much okay that's
right there's a lot of people in monica
that nobody has any idea how much money
they have you know what i'm saying it's
only what's reported which is like okay
he sold his company for 300 million in
2011. and then that's all that's all the
information that there is out there
um
and we'd like to keep it that way so
yeah
you know
and do you like you mentioned earlier uh
not to take it to a dismal place but
you seem not too concerned about growing
your income right now and you're not
worried about when you get older and you
need money for like you know and
medicare and yeah some medicare like
because you said well australia has free
medicare so
i could just go home expenses when
you're older and maybe you know don't
want to work and stuff like that want to
retire
you said you're just you're not worried
do you does that translate to you not
really caring about scaling your income
right now um no i definitely care about
like growing like scaling my income and
stuff um it's just a matter for me it's
like having the right business and doing
it with the right business
um
and just letting it happen naturally um
because sometimes you know
out of nowhere someone's just gonna
offer you a bunch of money to make them
a video or something which i think is
just cool like i like to do it like that
you know i like i like i prefer to make
a bunch of money in one go i don't like
to like
you know when people
that's why i hate businesses where it's
like you're gonna sell like a hundred
thousand of this five dollar product and
it's all shipping out and stuff like
that i hate it i hate that like i like
to like do things where it's like okay
here's like five bands make a video like
you know i'm saying or like i make like
you know 10k off doing a paradise black
trip or something like this you know
what i'm saying and when you make 10
grand like that what do you do with it
do you still save up money or are you
pretty month to month because like you
said you don't really yeah i just save
or invest i do i do i do though yeah um
i didn't used to and it was really
annoying because no matter how much even
if you're making a lot of money you
always bottom out it's [ __ ] annoying
so
um
yeah i'm invested in like some nfts and
crypto and stuff do you have any
traditional investments no stock no
index funds i feel like i hate
i don't feel like it's fast enough it's
not fast it's not fast enough so fast
i like to live so all
the money is is crypto nfts
yeah what crypto um just eth
okay all right
and then i got some dead fellas cool you
know what that is it's like a nf team
okay it's cool you worried about the nft
market kind of
softening a little bit yeah the sales
are down 92 percent yeah i don't know
it's just it's terrible it's a roller
coaster okay you know zang so when it's
off the top when it's down it's down but
you don't have any desire for like a
good solid diversified vanguard index
fund we could set that up today for you
how much do you make well eight percent
a year than an average year well
with dividends reinvested of course
partially adjusted for inflation
yeah hopefully adjusted for inflation
over over 20 years yeah
it doesn't work with me you said that
the
one of my business partners learned that
with me it's like we make money it's
gone
but do you think though that that sets
the like your your level your threshold
is so high that like an eight percent
return is just like why why is that
worth your time because you've seen like
such bigger i'm just always trying to
look for i'm always just trying to make
more money i'm just trying to look for
like how can i make more money you know
what i mean rather than
like i don't have like enough where it's
like i would put it in a vanguard
account and just leave it on eight
percent and then i'm making a cool
amount of money you know what i'm saying
because as i said like i'll get a bunch
of money and i spend and i get more and
i spend it so it's like
i don't know i'm always just looking for
something bigger right and then
eventually going into my dad's business
is my plan so how confident are you
about the inheritance and going into
your dad's business like is there a
chance he could say you know what
changed my mind it's going to charity no
no my dad's very much like me you know
what i'm saying we're like we believe in
like empire you know what i'm saying and
like
our family and everything so my dad like
you know
me and him are pretty similar in the way
that we want we want to
we wouldn't give it to charity now but
uh
i could definitely get myself written
out of the will if i became a junkie or
something sure yeah you know what's your
relationship with them now yeah it's
good it's very good um it got very i i
went to prison in japan and that was
sort of like
it was after a summer in santa pay and
i've really been pissing off my parents
and i spent a bunch of money on their
credit card and they have do they give
you a credit card no no no like i took
it and like went out and like i'm not
supposed to to do that and then i and so
i got in a bunch of trouble and left
basically ran away back to la i was
living with my friend in his spare room
um
and then i was like oh [ __ ] i made this
video i was still working for a designer
so i still had to make some money and i
made this one video sort of talking
about like what happened and like where
my life was at now and how i was like
staying with my friend all this [ __ ]
started getting a bunch of views and i
go on tour with designer to
to
like asia so we first go to south korea
and then we go out in a club and it's
lit and like there's like me and design
me designer and he's homie where
everyone else in the club is just korean
and so like and a lot of just girls like
tables would only girls and they're kind
of dancing like it was the lego movie
and everyone was just like so happy
and like me and designer just like in
the middle everyone's like just praising
us
they're like yeah bobby's in the house
we got that diner all this [ __ ] so it
was like lit we go out
next day next in the morning so we
didn't sleep we go straight into the
plane i'm super hungover and i'm like
and like i get out in japan and the
customs like checks my bag and they find
adderall and they're like this is super
illegal i'm like what i was like i don't
know i was like just take it i'm sorry
and then they're like no no no you're
going to jail i was like oh [ __ ]
and then like um
so then i'm in [ __ ] chat was in
japanese prison for like two months two
months yeah
in prison yeah
how do you not have the money or the
resources that your dad could say like
hey we're getting a lawyer it's japan
you know what i mean like obviously that
could have happened or anything no no no
especially only for japanese people but
then so i was just stuck no phone calls
like no communication and you're just
like there and you've got to wait for
your truck do parents just not
like how would they not track you down
or like find somebody they know they
knew but like here's the thing in japan
is 99 conviction rate so it doesn't
[ __ ] matter if you get a lawyer or
not if you're getting charged with
something that's it you're getting a
charger there so they were like just
tell the truth that's what this u.s um
military like the head of the military
lawyer came in to see me and he was like
just tell the truth like you're not a
dealer right and i was like no and he's
like so you're going to be fine just
tell the truth they're going to give you
a two-year suspended sentence and you go
home you can't come back to japan how
does that take two months to go through
that though because i don't know it just
took ages to get to the trial because
the guy thought i was a dealer like he
was like he was thinking i was a dealer
and you're thinking i was like trying to
hide something from it i was like no bro
like and then it ended up just being
like all right fine put me to trial and
they like just said like they made me
promise to never do drugs again and i
was like i'm like i was confused because
i was just trying to come and be a
productive productive citizen and then
do my work very well for design because
when you're on tour like you're sleeping
shits like you know what i mean
and what was it like in prison um
well like first month i'm just on the
floor like sleeping on a gym mat there's
a couple other guys in there one guy was
really funny called toshi
um and then the second month i was in
like a c you moved to a bigger prison
but luckily i was on an island
apparently tokyo is like
hectic
so i'm on this island and i go and take
you get your own cell a little bed and
[ __ ] there's a rule book with a lot of
rules
um you just sort of stay quiet and like
read books but they had nice food at the
second one first one i lost a lot of
weight because it's just three bowls of
rice a day three bowls of rice yeah
that's it that's it nothing else there's
no sauce
i was so much bigger than any of them so
it's like i was i lost like six kilos or
something and they checked me into the
other prison they weighed me and he's
like all right he gets an extra bowl of
rice and and all this [ __ ] when i was in
the new one but then you weren't like
they had actual food rather than just
rice did you ever feel like you were in
danger because i've seen stories of like
the us prison system and it's like just
it you could you could die at like any
point if you cross the wrong person at
the wrong time yeah you feel safer yeah
well yeah because you got to understand
like in japan to commit a crime is a
very low threshold so the people in
there are not criminals like they're
just people who like kind of [ __ ] up a
little bit you know what i mean like the
one there was one guy in there and he
like he didn't want to pay tax on this
gold that he had so he tried to sneak it
in without declaring it so he's in
prison and then there's like another guy
like he was just like he was just happy
all the time because he didn't care he
was just stealing stuff he was like
that's what he did it was just like
stealing makeup so when you they go to
trial are they supposed to just admit
what they did
yeah you're supposed to tell the true if
you tell the truth
then they're more likely to give you
like a more they're going to give you a
more fair judgment is what they say so
if you just start telling the truth as
much as as much as you can just say the
truth then they're going to look more
favorably upon you kind of like that i
mean i always believe they'll say this
be honest about it yeah well i mean
technically graham you're supposed to be
you're oh yeah i mean under under oath
i guess i know where what you're doing
yeah but i don't think that the does the
us legal system take that into
consideration honesty i think i know if
you plead guilty
tickets like they give you some
favorable you know i feel like some of
that is just
it's just to get the conviction rates
it's like hey if you plead guilty to
this you're gonna lower it
making a deal in the u.s yeah you make a
deal with um the prosecutor you know and
if you admit to it you get a better
sentence typically that's i feel like
it's just a you know a churning through
whereas in japan it's about more like
honesty and just don't do it again yeah
honesty don't do it again swear to god
you'll never use adderall again and all
this stuff whatever they have lower
crime rates than the us
i mean here's probably way higher if
they have a lower threshold no i know no
no no so it's like obviously it's not
like hectic crime like here it's like
there's
to go to jail here is really difficult i
feel especially in california like it's
really hard to end up in jail for an
extended period of time so it's like i
feel the people in there are really
criminals you know so it's like must be
a lot more dangerous to be in prison
there than in japan you know because in
japan they're also like super strict
with the rules and the guards are very
on top of everything and everything's
like to the dot exact minute everything
this happens this happens
so it's not
like you know
it's not scary like that you were at no
point scared well there was this one guy
three cells down and he like killed his
mom with a toothbrush
and it was on the news because this guy
came in after me and he was like bro
like the guy like in this cause he was
isolated and he just looked really weird
and like we were like and he's like yeah
that guy killed his mom with a
toothbrush
and then like we all got next to each
other like brushing our teeth next to
each other and i was like like a couple
of times i'm like next to this [ __ ]
guy and i would be like in the mirror
just death staring him straight in the
eyes i'm like no
were you taller than me yeah i'm like
way bigger so i'm like no yeah
you know how do you do that yeah i guess
you must have filed it down so for a
reference too uh japan so on on the
crime index so again it could be skewed
because they could have more convictions
but they are 63 one being the worst um
and then u.s is
135.
so they so they have more crime higher
but like i said that could be also
because like he was saying if they have
you know a lower level of of crime and
like i said i don't know um but if you
can get arrested for just right you know
jaywalking jaywalking
you know then they could have a you know
a higher so so there's no way for us to
know exactly yeah i mean i guess just
look at violent crimes or something like
that yeah it would be a different
statistic but wow
interesting how was that to get out
um so cool wow you feel incredible i
mean it was honestly it was like
it was great rehab as well because i'm
not smoking any cigarettes or drinking
or anything remotely and like you you're
so you're just reading books and kind of
like just being healthy and like you get
to go to the workout place for 30
minutes a day
so you work out as hard as you can for
30 minutes it almost was like you had a
very good schedule and everything was
organized so i was like okay if i'm
gonna be here for two years
i'm not that mad yeah cause i'll come
out
and like i'll just be like a whole new
guy i'll be shredded
but at least two months was cool because
i came out and i just felt like so
healthy i'm always curious like what
happens to people's responsibilities
like two months like rent credit cards
yields
how do those get paid how did they not
just like tell you you leave it on the
street and like your car gets towed or
something i know yeah i mean
i didn't really have that many bills
my friend
when i was in there my friend was
running up my amazon
because i left it on the tv he was
buying movies and subscribers well you
were in prison came out i came i was
like bro you spent 200 and i'm in
[ __ ] jail
[Laughter]
you still friends with him yeah yeah he
didn't know he thought it was his
account
and then um
uh and i guess my my parents paid my
rent no one was in there
so they knew you were in there how did
you repair your relationship with your
parents well that's what i was saying so
honestly it was like in a really bad
state with my dad i'd been kicked out i
was cut off i was living in a land my
own i go on tour and i go to jail but
what that what happened then was like a
lot of growing up in my family it's
always been like um a lot of like back
and forth between me and my dad
especially right because i'm the only
son he's always been very harsh for me
if he gives me a punishment it's like
it's like that's it like you're [ __ ]
right um
and so when that happened and then i
ended up in jail it was like oh wow like
maybe it was like all like it was just
very like my dad was just worried more
you know what i mean and it was like i
came out and we were like all very very
close again and we're like we're sorry
like i was like i'm so sorry and my
parents are so sorry so it wasn't like
he was mad at me he was honestly just
more worried because he was i was in
japan and there's no way he could help
me and everything and i was like what if
i ended up in there for two years or
whatever so i think
going to jail honestly made me realize
that how important my family is and like
it gave me like i realized i need to
have a lot more respect for my parents
and like and that my life is fine
already like i shouldn't you know you
know be abusing my position or anything
anymore and i don't know it was just it
was a big eye-opener for sure
for on both sides though like my dad
realized like you know as well like yeah
i think we just became a lot nicer to
each other afterwards it was it was
interesting got it and if you if i'm
taking you want eventually kids
yeah how would you raise them
differently than you were raised um
i would i'm gonna i would just be a lot
more present um i would
um first of all my son's gonna be called
draco like draco malfoy oh really you
already have the name planned out
actually it's done it's gonna happen now
it's gonna be draco okay why because
it's because like i feel like draco
malfoy yeah
and like i feel like it's a cool name i
feel like that's a strong draco more
like a villain though like yeah i don't
want anyone yeah to be able to shorten
his name because i don't i feel like
that's right not a power move yeah it
drake yeah but it's powerful draco bro
it's and it's more bougie than drake
like what am i doing i mean i'll give
you this it's a unique name i i don't
know anybody named draco
there was thanksgiving named draco if
you could no no no i like my name is it
short for robert yeah my name is robert
so you just don't like how people
shorten your name and now you're like
i'm not that's why i call myself bobby
because i like bobby i feel like it's
more catchy it's it's it's easy easier
to say jack is his name is shortened
from jacqueline yeah see is the word
it's like it's not it's not
i just made that up
but it's so full it's so formal to say
like robert like it's like you know what
i mean i feel like that's so formal i
don't like saying it rob
like he was like rob or like robert or
whatever but it's like i don't know when
i'm in the uk like i have to say like
robert and it's like i feel like it's so
formal so i was just like i said bobby
and it just works everywhere yeah you
never you never miss understand that's a
name where like as you grow older it's
like you know you're bobby when you're
young and then you go to robert in like
your mid-30s and then you go to bob when
you're like 50. yeah i'll be bumped when
i'm 50
with raising my kid right draco
i'm going to like push him into sport at
a really young age like
like make him like yeah like quidditch
so like get him on the quidditch team
and but like really push him and like
you know what i mean because i wish i
had that i wish i wish that one of my
parents had pushed me to do a sport or
music or anything yeah and it could be
magic
no no
but draco you got to go all the way
absolutely
no absolutely oh yeah that's a good
quote what if what if he's into
something completely different like you
know you want to continue on this wealth
but he's like you know what i just want
to chill
don't worry
he wants to chill just once he doesn't
get a chill no no no no no no jacob's
gonna be a beast i mean he's gonna be a
beast i'm going to push i'm going to
because i'm going to say i'm going to
push him from a very young age he's
going to be incredible at like tennis or
something i want him to be incredible at
a sport so that when he's by the time
he's finished school he'd be like wow
i'm so glad that i'm really really sick
of this sport and now i'm so fit and i
can just play tennis for the rest of my
life like something like that i wish the
tiger woods had done that more i always
i wish that i i had piano lessons going
on i had piano
i persisted through that although kind
of it was annoyance when i was young
yeah but now i'm like god like i have a
friend my best friend grew up and he's
like super good at guitar and you can
still play that and like whip it out and
like i don't know play cool music and
i'm like god i wish i still had peanut
butter yeah
that way about piano but it gives you
like a discipline from a young age i
think i think i want to give my son a
lot more discipline i didn't have that i
didn't have discipline but my mom was
just with my older sister riding horses
my dad wasn't there so i just on my own
but now how do you feel about the fact
that like i think it's 90 something
percent of wealth is
lost after the third generation and so
you're the second so there would be one
more generation and it's gone
you worried about that no franco's gonna
be disciplined why is that what do you
mean 90
how wealth uh
hold on i'll tell you the actual
statistic here seventy percent of
affluent families will have lost their
wealth by the third generation i feel
like affluence is also a little bit
different than like billionaire status
oh this one says ninety percent of lost
the wealth by the third generation
i just feel like i feel like it's just
accumulating so much like and there's we
have a trust as well so it's not like
when my dad dies i'm just gonna have all
the [ __ ] money in my bank account
just go spend it it's like we have a
trust like a family office and stuff so
it's like you know i'd have to get
approved for all the things that i'd
want to do or whatever you know what i
mean so it's like
would always make sure that it's making
money that's what you know it's real
when there's a family office jack you
ever heard of this
never heard of the family office so a
family office is just yeah seriously
it's like a roommates except for wealth
planning tax management lawyers states
um basically anything that a family
would need on like the back end
uh for planning their wealth
is to make sure that they can never go
poor again basically to make sure that
they they get the proper tax
optimization accounting well that's why
we live in monaco so it's like yeah you
have to pay tax right but but the
problem is
when i'm i'm american american citizen
do you know what i'm saying so i'm like
i'm gonna have to be taxed
but whatever yeah but yeah so anyway
it's about 250 to 500 million dollars is
when people typically have their own
family office the dedicated family
office wow it's yeah it's crazy once you
go like down those leagues yeah you get
your own family office of like you have
a team of people around you making sure
that like that money is put to its best
use and you guys are fiduciary yeah yeah
do you split into the idea is it your
own family office yes you know it's all
right we have like yeah do they do your
taxes too no i just i do them because
they're american american taxes okay
um
i'm sure it's i'm sure it's pretty basic
on your end it's like income coming in
and then like 90 is a write-off yeah i
say like so much because i spend so much
of my money so it's like i don't have to
pay much because i'm spending it all and
this i'm a youtuber so i'm spending it
on stuff that i'm trying to film and
[ __ ] you know yeah do you ever want to
leave california you're pretty content
there well yeah i mean like like i said
like i'm not like
accumulating a lot of wealth yet yeah so
for me california still makes a lot of
sense to be there like i know that you
moved you moved here because there's no
tax and stuff but you're you're you're
accumulating you're trying to accumulate
a bunch of wealth yeah right obviously
in california that's annoying because
you're constantly getting [ __ ] taxed
on everything you need tax when you're
going buying things everything
everything has tax today yeah how will
your
life change when you get you know 200
million dollars 300 million dollars
i don't know man
you know
like
i'd just be calling i don't know like by
that time like i'll be like older and
like i'll already have like i've made a
bunch of money myself
um but nothing close to that but you
know what i'm saying i'll be more
cooling hopefully of a family and stuff
so how do you plan to make more money by
your by yourself
um
with paradise black what is that it's my
members club do you want to grow that
and like because when i'm older i want
to
have my own like a building like a
members club as well which i think would
be really sick
i just like that you guys go around like
you mentioned earlier you travel to
certain locations and you can yeah
figure out like all the amenities and
the food yes so you've got to party well
and you want to share with other people
so i've been partying since i was like
12. you know what i'm saying and like
i've been to doing all of these things
every year for for
like you know 10 years now so since i
was 17 really i started going out in
that jet set vibe
um
so i know like all the people i know all
the places i know what you need to do
and everything when you go to like the
monaco grand prix or coachella and all
these things and i have a lot of access
like i know a lot of people i know how
to get into certain parties that you
just wouldn't get invited to and stuff
like that so
basically what we're offering is is a
high level of access on these trips um
and it's just turnkey so it's like you
and you don't have to touch your wallet
either so it's like you just pay a
one-off fee you come and everything's
just organized
but here's the thing jack that i've
noticed is that when you have when you
have the money to pay for something like
that you typically already have the
connections that's not true though
there's so many guys that have money
that have no idea
about what's going on you know because
they're busy making money they don't
they're not out on this whole party
scene like knowing people don't you
think there's a high turnover of people
like that type they don't have the
connections that type would just get it
out of their system for a year or two
and then there'd be a constant influx
outflox of new people leaving yeah i
mean i don't know we've only been
running for a year so i'm just
you know we're just trying to do some do
some stuff like that how much does it
cost
many between 15 and 30 000 depending on
the trip and what does that get you well
we fly in like some tier one girls we
get like you know a villa it depends
where we're at or like maybe a boat um
and then you know paid that pace for
your tables and
and transport like in mykonos we have
like a really sick driver there's like a
sprinter van he's called george he's lit
um and do you go along with them like
you're a partner yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you're right
there's like you're coming to party with
me and i'm like i'm like [ __ ] sending
it and you're having because i'm very
fun to party with like i'll make sure
everyone's having a great time you know
what i'm saying no short and nothing
ever there's always something happening
yeah you know um
which i think people love they like to
do that you know it's cool to be in a
group as well especially when you're
young guys you know because you you're
going up against like you know
six-year-old dudes who have a hundred
million dollars in the bank and they're
just like don't care you know so it's
like for young guys like yeah you're
making money but it's like you don't
have a hundred g's to spend but you
maybe have fifteen to 30 000 you know so
you go together and then you got a cool
situation going on how long does that
last let's say it's 30 grand is that
like a month is that a weekend week or
that's a week yeah how much do you make
off of that
not
not enough yeah okay because we're still
like more like we spend all the money to
make the trip as cool as it can be okay
but you get that you get the experience
for free yeah but you put it all
together and then you get to the
connection and photography and
everything while you're there which a
lot of these a lot of the time like
people do these trips and then they just
forget about it and it's like you spend
all that money you don't have anything
to show for
anything to show for it so i think it's
really cool to have like video of it
imagine like a trophy at the end yeah
you completed the uh the week the two
weeks whatever it is how many people
have done that so far what's like the
typical person who buys that we've done
three trips okay um typical person's
like young guy anywhere between you know
20 and 30.
um
wants to party wants to meet girls makes
a good amount of money a lot of the like
in the last trip a lot of guys were like
in tech three of the guys were in tech
like doing stuff you know like online
like one guy ai for
e-commerce i don't know tech yeah but uh
and then the other guys like in real
estate from switzerland some of my
friends um
and yeah and then how do you get the the
girls are they just like friends of
friends are they hired out like yeah
friends or friends okay i like to just
do it like with friends and stuff i mean
that's a lot of what what the reason
you'd want to come on their choice with
me is because i'm friends with a lot of
these influencer girls and and girls
that seem out of reach to to these guys
um because they're down to you know if
they're down to come on these trips
because
they know they're gonna hang out with
like young guys and it's not like you're
going on a trip with a creepy old guy
you know it's like dubai or something so
it's fun yeah how common is that i heard
a rumor
uh i think it was on the impulsive
podcast i think it was mike that was
talking about like a lot of those like
instagram models are kind of like
doing their stuff yes
yeah
well here's the thing it's like if
you're a pretty girl on instagram and
you have like a certain amount of
followers yeah you just get these offers
like my girlfriend gets them all the
time like
i have
hey like i have a
very important client in dubai who's
looking for fresh young faces to come
out and party you'll be paid this amount
all your flights taken care of you'll
get to go shopping and all this [ __ ]
like literally like a whole like just an
offer they said how much how much are
those offers
between like they'll be like yeah we'll
give you like 20 000
and will take you shopping you can stay
in a hotel and you just have to like
come to like some parties with
the shake whatever really yeah
oh my gosh now is there anything is
there anything ever implied after that
or
just like flat out like just show up
yeah they just like show up i mean i've
also heard it's not like sketchy either
because like these guys a lot of them
just want these girls around them for
image rather than these sketched out go
to another country yeah it's like some
random especially yeah i don't like
being in countries where the laws are
all weird yeah has she ever has she ever
done that
who your girlfriend no no absolutely not
how does that how does that feel for you
to be like in a relationship with
someone who gets these offers i think
it's 20 grand really it's so hard to say
no to i think it's funny to just see
guys like thirsting over her and stuff i
think it's yeah
because they know that yeah they
obviously know that i'm her boyfriend as
well because you can see on instagram
like you could see so i think so but why
go for her with the boyfriend i don't
get this
it's a power trip thing as well you know
what i mean they want it they think they
can take bobby's girlfriend on the
[ __ ] trip if they pay her but like
it's not the case yeah wouldn't they
just throw out an offer like a hundred
that like is there a price that you
would encourage her be like honey it's
like 500 grand just like i just like i
trust you just have fun this weekend be
safe
come back and like
is there an amount where it's like you
could be one like
yeah like maybe like 200k okay imagine
the guy with the yacht is watching this
yeah the bigger game
i was like
no hard feelings
but it's like
250.
[Laughter]
yeah
gosh
i would just i feel uncomfortable i'm
feeling comfortable with that like he's
doing again yeah but i would i i don't
know i couldn't let me uh let me flip
the question on youtube
is there a price for you no oh wait for
for what for you to go
yeah i just
no
no even if for a million no 10 million
yes man i made it then
there's a million dollar for a weekend
it's like you can you can fight my goal
for 10 million
gosh
it's just like
no no no no no no none of that
but if it's like if it's platonic for 10
million dollars for a weekend party just
partying oh i don't know i don't like i
would want like i would want to say no
but i also know it's like a significant
amount of money that would you know that
would be her money so
you know
i don't know i mean you don't need the
money but here's the thing i feel like
people want too much money you know what
i mean
like i feel like it like 10 mil like
[ __ ] whatever you're calling at that
point you know
yeah i don't know you probably don't
think they have great great graham's
going to get i think
i just think there's always like a you
know safety net like right now
there's nothing that says the market
can't go down 50 percent yeah then
you're cut in half so by starting off
with a larger amount you could still
drop that 50 and and have more because i
like the safety plus a big buffer yeah
like i love
i so i feel more comfortable with that
yeah require a larger amount and that's
just for me though yeah yeah i just take
the worst case uh account and worst case
scenario into account first and i'd like
work backwards from there like what's
the worst that's ever happened okay like
a 70 drop during the great depression
okay let's plan for that okay and if it
never happens
i'm good if it does happen then i plan
for it i see that's how i see things
it's very good so guys we're going to do
a new segment here once again graham
posted on his instagram asking you guys
questions to ask bobby so all right so
go ahead we're going to start off with
nato brian oh what's up man okay so uh
he asked one that i was thinking the
first thing you walked in here yeah how
much did your shirt cost
oh i made this yeah i made this shirt
for my brand like you used to have a
clothing brand but yeah it cost i sold
them for like 110 did you strategically
rip each hole i they were they were
strategically ripped but in power it's
made in paris but then i i ripped it
more i like to like i like to look
trashy i like to look like i'm poor to
be honest i feel like it's cool you know
[Laughter]
someone's gonna clip that out
because i feel like if you confidently
wear ripped clothing like that they're
like okay this guy's insanely rich
that's what i'm saying i feel like it's
like okay like if you're if you just got
money it's like okay you're gonna wear
stuff that everyone says versace on it
or gucci all over right because you're
like you want everyone to know that it's
cool and it's going to be clean but when
you when you're me you wear a [ __ ] up
t-shirt [ __ ] up shoes
but you're still going to the party and
you're on the coolest table so i've said
that for the longest time in beverly
hills it was always like the person who
walks down with like the gucci head to
toe they're not buying anything they
show up just to be seen and like do
window shopping but the guy who pulls up
in the rolls royce with 30 sweatpants a
torn tee well usually like a walmart
t-shirt
scruffy hasn't shaved in a week like
that's the guy who has nothing to
nothing to prove
and he's that that's usually the
customer that like you
would want to cater to uh craziest thing
you've ever spent money on um this
[ __ ]
this like f-355 1999 ferrari that i
bought for a hundred thousand
um and then it was just i got very good
shifted by this shady car salesman and
it just was
didn't work and it was always broken
and then 355 though yeah yeah i was like
super mad and then like i tried to sell
it and it was only worth 50. so 54. so i
lost 50 bands
what did you get and i barely got to
drive it yeah what are you doing now i
don't have a car in l.a i always just
like my friends have my roommates have
cars and i'm never here i always travel
and stuff so it's like i don't know i'm
in a car yet
and they just got my license too
when like well i had one but in the uk
oh okay would you rather fight 100
duck-sized horses or one horse-sized
duck um
i feel like i would
i'd fight the big duck
one big duck you're a rather sizable
person you're pretty [ __ ] as a duck
you know what i mean tackle it yeah a
bunch of horses could be really strong
like little for the courses are strong
and there was a lot of them you'd be
overwhelmed that's a good point all
right that's a good question why do you
want to be famous or go viral um
i don't know i just
feel like it's cool to be known
especially amongst like i like i like to
be known
um amongst
like my scene i think and that that's
what i achieved and so like ever since i
kind of been more complacent i didn't
grow as much after because i
i just like make videos for my crowd
rather than making trying to like grow
as much because i'm not i don't have the
work ethic to be honest i like to make
you know
i like to make a really cool video and i
feel like to do that you can really max
max out at like two videos a month to
make like a super sick one um but then
you think if you want to be known you
gotta play to the algorithm you gotta
post more than that
once a week minimum
yeah who's someone that's doing what you
want to be doing but doing it like
perfectly
um
i feel like it's almost like david
dobrik david
yeah when he was doing like a lot of
those party like part-time vlogs yeah i
like i like i like just fun vlogs like
that i like david derby's vlogs i mean
yeah i'm trying to like this year i'm
trying to do it a lot more it was like
over the past two years like because of
like covered and stuff like i just felt
like it was really hard to party and
travel and and stuff so it was harder to
pump out the videos i also like to just
do it like more naturally i see it as
like a progression into film and tv
rather than just being a youtuber
forever
because my goal is ultimately to make my
own film um and i've been contacted by
like a huge film producer before and he
said like you definitely have an idea
like the way that you need to do it is
just
you got to come up with a great great
story
um
and then a studio will just they'll if
it's great enough like they'll fund it
don't worry about trying to get funding
from people and stuff like that the
studios right now he was saying like you
know they've got huge budgets and not
enough ideas what is your biggest
problem right now
i want to be more consistent with with
my youtube videos
how can you fix that um
i need more money
i want to because i want to like spend a
lot of money on my videos
you know what i mean but you're already
like you already like i'm looking at
this thing how could you possibly spend
more
well what would you do where where i
want to have a private jet pajama party
but you really think i would do well on
youtube because like you got to think
arac is not spending that that much i
think that would do well on youtube a
private jet pajama party yeah
i really think it would it's just a
complete difference 30 seconds i think
that's 30 seconds that's not 30 seconds
very a private jet pajama party birth i
would watch that for like
can you just but can't you just rent one
of those jets that not up in the air and
just pretend it's up in the air like
because i want to draw i want to i want
to
i want to like do like a drop as well so
people like float a bit i've done that
before in the plane
can you rent out one of those zero
gravity planes wow eric did that he did
i'm thinking like aarock's getting like
what do you think five ten million views
he's doing
i don't know how he comes up i remember
like a year and a half ago he was like
i have no ideas and they're
brainstorming now it seems like every
week i'm like how did you think it just
has people that create ideas for him
i don't know he's a great he's a grafter
but he works so hard you know
he deserves it when do you think it's
like getting too old to party or do you
think that just doesn't exist because we
have a friend jeremy financial education
he has a podcast with graham and this
other guy andre and we were all talking
about like
when can you stop partying when is that
awkward to be to show your face at the
club and jeremy's all like uh once
you're 30. you know if your age
you know it's crazy the people who party
the most some of those clubs are
probably in their mid 30s to early 40s
and those are the people who go like
nuts at the club yeah
what do you think i'm going to be
partying to i'm dead i'm rolling stone
you know i'm saying like i'm going to be
in monaco seven years old like five
hookers with me like cooling like that's
me you know what i'm saying but like i
don't know what everyone else wants to
do but like i'm trying to be i'm trying
to like have fun i think it just has to
do with the confidence and how well like
you you fit in with how much crowd you
have to bobby what would you say to me a
young man who's never been to a club
you've never been to a club no never how
old are you
23 23 wow
or don't you don't want to go no i would
love to go why haven't you been uh
well there's
graham wouldn't go with me
i highly doubt alex would want to go
with me yeah my housemates they're
pretty indifferent about it yeah jack
has to go with either grant navarre
kevin paffrey i'd say go with someone
who's i've also never been to the bottle
service yeah we gotta go with someone i
would go with you i've never been to the
club ever i need two weeks notice to get
into this and i want to go around well
here's the thing the club is [ __ ] if you
don't it's probably especially in vegas
it's probably not fun unless you're with
someone that has a table yes
you have to go with something like if
you went with your buddies i guarantee
you would you would have a better time
at just one of the bars like the hotel
bars
just chilling and hanging out and
talking otherwise you see the dance
floor in vegas and it's like
sardines of people that's not fun the
dance floor no no i mean when you're
like
everyone has like this much space
between each other yeah everybody you
want to be
pushing and you've got to be on a table
or some some the whole idea of like at
the club like you're going to have fun
if you're doing some sort of something
that's more vip than anyone else because
everyone's just in a club like you know
trying to look at each other what is
this person what is that person doing
but it's like if you're on a table and
you've got your own girls and your
friends and everything you can dance
there you get drinks that's that's fine
but if you're in the club and you're
just like hanging out like it's like
what the [ __ ] you got to wait 20 minutes
to get a drink at the bar and you got to
pay a cover yeah
how much of the club is about just going
and having fun dancing and meeting
people and just having a good time
versus a status like competitive
environment yeah i'd say it depends
where you are
like la's very much like who are you
it's like everyone's being too cool like
in the club like it's because there's a
lot of like you know influencers and
yeah and then like so it's like la is
not as fun to go out and everyone knows
that it's more like at the aft after
parties like is where you're gonna have
fun but in like london
you go out and it's just like busting
like so fun so fun to go out in london
or like you know in the mediterranean
and the summer you know beach clubs like
that's that's fun i'd say like la's more
of a scene that's why that they know
that and they know that to get cool
people to come like
and like goals and stuff there's always
promoter tables and like you know all
these kind of all these people are going
for free because they want they want to
have cool people at the club that's what
makes the club cool
yeah like jason would get in all the
time for free and anywhere he would ever
want to go is just walk right into the
front door because yeah yeah right but
but also it's just like once you have
that connection they want you there and
they want people who go there who have a
good time and that people like
yeah so if you're gonna go there and
like get belligerent they're not gonna
have you back but if you go there have a
good time you leave and you know what's
the most like luxurious thing that
you've ever done
where where let's say someone did some
service for you or you bought something
where you're like holy cow like this is
nice the
most luxurious thing i've ever done
was
when my dad first started his company we
went on like a like a world tour and and
he just said no he saw this company and
he bought a jet and then we went on a
tour so we went from sydney we went to
fiji hawaii
alaska
um
chicago
uk
and then
um
finished off in
south of france
which was cool how was your music i was
like that was when i was like 15 16.
it was crazy because i'd never been in a
jet before and all of a sudden we're
like in our jet with our name on the
back and i was like this is sick we're
saying the four seasons in hawaii
just cooling like that was probably like
like the most lux thing
i think i've ever done it was sick huh
what other questions you have for us um
how do you what do you think i should do
what do you think i should do
i think you need to pose more and i
think there's only so much that you
could do with money
and i feel like at a certain point
there's always going to be someone who
could spend more money than you like
steve will do it
no matter what you do he will put that
to shame by doing something else and
like so i think you need to post more
but find an angle and i think
the b-roll is good but i wish there's
more of a story
with every video of like a start to
finish like a david dobrik vlog
where people get to know you more okay
um that's what i would i don't think it
needs to cost more yeah because i just i
i want to make it
i i just like
i don't like doing like for example like
what erect does how it's like a fool
like it's an idea and it's this whole
video right i like to just have it like
be my life almost like reality tv yeah
that's what i i have fun doing i think
the issue though on youtube people want
relatability they want to feel like
you're their friend and the reason david
dobrik did so well is even though he's
like you know living in an 8 million
house you feel like you're with him and
you're like part of his friend group and
you're all like hanging out and i feel
like with you people watch more as like
an observer like they're at the zoo just
like watching this creature that's like
oh the billionaire son and they feel a
disconnect whereas like what prompts
them to keep coming back besides like a
wow factor and then after a while you'll
you'll keep the same wow factor and
you'll have to keep one upping it one
upping him to be like oh how crazy is it
gonna be today but i think building that
relationship with your audience is
really important and i think just
humility of it and just being more
relatable i don't mean that you have to
like you know eat it chipotle to do that
but i mean like i think just being more
vulnerable posting more i think twice a
week that's what i do
okay
cool but i think you could continue most
of like what you're doing but like the
stuff about like living like that for
five grand a month like i think
yeah there's probably gonna be ten
percent of people who are like it's a
fake and just get but you don't care
about ninety percent of people i think
would would actually see that as like
really cool
and
resonate with that more okay nice
cool that's good all right
thank you so much thank you for coming
on man did we cover anything you want to
talk about yeah man thank you for having
me heck yeah that was really fascinating
thank you we'll link to your information
down below oh one one more thing you
paid to tosi a thousand dollars yeah for
him to make a video why i
i feel like i like a toesie more than
the most out of anyone that's made
videos on me okay and he's always giving
me advice and stuff so
i had like a thousand dollars budget to
market um for paradise black and i was
like i'll just give it to a toesie and
get him to make a video and he was like
oh i [ __ ] say you paid me i was like
you're [ __ ] that's cool i had a
thousand dollars to blow on a video like
you know are you friends with him yeah
yeah yeah i met him once before he's
really nice i've never met him but we
damn yeah he's really cool i like him
he's cool
well of all the people who could get a
thousand dollars i'm happy it was him
yeah yeah i felt like he was the only
one who deserved it
cool
good stuff well thank you so much
it was honor meeting you and uh we'll
link to your information down below in
the description for free
by the way doesn't cost anything
so thank you so much really appreciate
it but oh did you get your free stock
down below in the description when you
sign up for public with the code gram oh
i'll have to get that you'll have to do
that wow worth all the way up to a
thousand bucks that's sick you could
also add five
thanks so much and until next time
cool that was great that was great i
really enjoyed that